Hello, how are you? Greetings too, Jaramillo,
with the briefing for
today, Monday, May 24. The
unemployment department says that errors in the system
do not allow people to declare their
weekly benefits. The agency says that
some people cannot find the
link that directs them.  go to the page
to complete your statements others
if found but get an
error message the department is doing
its best to resolve this
issue immediately
void gaming will be hosting a
job fair tomorrow within the gold coast this
event will be from 1-4pm
interviews will be done right there later the company is
looking to hire for 100 positions you can
apply for jobs on their website
tmz.com
you can also check our home page
along with diagonal in spanish
for a complete list of
job fairs in the valley
and if you are looking for  a
unique experience at the time of receiving
the coronavirus vaccine then you
cannot miss  der this event attend
tonight the welcome to las
vegas
' sign facer and jansen vaccines will be
distributed in this place starting at
7 pm and if this were not enough
a photographer will be there to
remind you of this moment there will also be
trucks of  food in the parking lot
near the harley davidson branch
now we move on with the weather forecast
expecting a sunny day with
temps near normal in the
high 80s temps will continue to
rise until the end of the week as
well as the wind will return
have a nice tomorrow  day I am sabi jaramillo and
this was illustrated in Spanish
[Music]